-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
On a Thursday, no less!
Let's get to the news.
In a new interview,
President Biden defended
his handling of the U.S. troop
withdrawal from Afghanistan
and said, "I don't think
it was a failure."
But he said it the same way
you would compliment
your friend's play.
I thought it was pretty good!
[ Laughter ]
Officials from the
Treasury Department
are reportedly trying
to prevent the Taliban
from accessing the
International Monetary Fund.
Well, have you tried one
of those things
where they have to click
on all the fire hydrants?
I can never do 'em.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced yesterday
that nursing homes
must require their staff
to be vaccinated
against the coronavirus
or, more accurately,
President Biden
announced yesterday
that nursing homes
weren't already doing that?!
[ Laughter ]
The John Lewis
Voting Rights Advancement Act
that Democrats
unveiled this week
is expected to be passed
by the House.
Oh, sure,
it'll get through the House,
but can it get through Manchin?
["mansion"]
[ Laughter ]
A rare pun from Baze!
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
has filed retirement papers
with the state
so he can receive
his $50,000 annual pension.
For his part, Cuomo claims
it's not a cash grab,
but, rather,
a friendly cash embrace.
[ As Cuomo ]
I'm Italian.
[ Laughter ]
The new host of "Jeopardy!",
Mike Richards,
apologized yesterday for sexist
comments he made on a podcast.
At this rate, he's going to be
the first "Jeopardy!" host
to actually invoke
double jeopardy.
"Objection, I-I already got
in trouble for that one.
What?
Oh, sorry.
What is objection?"
[ Laughter ]
Facebook today launched a test
of its new virtual reality
remote work app,
where employees
can hold meetings
using an Oculus Quest 2 headset.
It's great, if the only thing
you hate about Zoom meetings is
that they aren't strapped
to your face.
[ Laughter ]
A rare photograph
of women's rights activist
Susan B. Anthony
is set to go up for auction
next month in New York.
It's rare
because it's a photo of her
kissing another girl
to get free drinks.
[ Laughter ]
Tell people.
Finally,
according to a new survey,
70% of Americans would give up
their smartphones for their pets
and certain pets
make you do that.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.